the race is on to use neuroscience and
technology
to plug the learning gap between poor
and rich children
recent research shows children's life
chances may depend less on sharing them
with knowledge and words
and more on opportunities to interact
with adults
that specific
type of communication is what is going
to really benefit the child long term
but is this enough
could a controversial focus on genetics
be what's needed to break the class
ceiling we are at a tipping point in
terms of how
genetics is going to shape our lives
[Music]
let's put your shoes on okay
it might look like shadara and her son
kevin are getting ready for a trip to
the playground
but this is no ordinary day oh my
goodness let's play when you want to
play first
every word they say is being recorded on
a tiny device known as a talk pedometer
[Music]
but instead of tracking steps it counts
words
the microphone is in the front and you
don't want to obstruct it you don't want
anything to block the sound
the device picks up how many adult words
he's hearing how much electronic noise
is in the background and how many turns
he's taking in talking to me when i
communicate with him
the pedometers continuously collect data
and a part of a scheme to transform how
children learn language
it makes me more mindful so now i'm
always considering when i'm getting him
ready i'm like am i talking to him
enough so let's go play with our toys
one influential study found that in the
first three years of a child's life
those from wealthy families will have
heard around 30 million more words than
those from poorer backgrounds
and this word gap can set them back for
years to come
kids in poverty hear
fewer adult words and it's not because
their parents are bad parents it's
because mom or dad is working two jobs
while the pedometers can be used by all
families including middle class ones
like shadara's
the scheme helps poor kids to bridge
this world gap
every week shidara gets a breakdown of
exactly how much she's spoken to her son
while he was wearing the device
we've had
several
teachers in our district go through the
program and when i've talked to them
after they get their first or second
report
almost all of their comments are i
thought i was talking with my kid way
more than this report actually shows
one study found this use of technology
and data analysis led to a 32 increase
in the number of words a child hears per
hour
everybody listen to me
but it's not just about increasing the
number of words children here
the schemes organizers are looking out
for the number of so-called
conversational turns
i tried to tell you last night papa the
area that we really encourage and try to
promote the most growth in is that back
and forth conversation between an adult
and a child there's tons of research
that shows that that specific type of
communication is what is going to really
benefit the child long term
neuroscience has shown the benefits of
conversational turns
as they appear to get around some of the
disadvantages of growing up
it is well established that if a child
grows up in poverty this affects their
growing brain
low socioeconomic status or other types
of disadvantage or adversity affect the
developing brain parts of the brain that
respond to threatening environments tend
to accelerate so that children can be
more resilient then there are other
parts of the brain showing slower
growth when exposed to adversity
[Music]
but when children are engaged in high
numbers of conversational turns
these differences in brain development
caused by their background don't seem to
matter
and regions of the brain associated with
language development expand
conversational turns is something
directly in the child's everyday
environment that seems to have an effect
over and above socioeconomic status
[Music]
yet despite these insights from
neuroscience and new tech
the gap in achievement between rich and
poor kids hasn't changed for decades
by the time they are 10 in 4th grade
lower income students will have a
reading score around 28 points below
their richer classmates
and this gap hasn't really changed in
the past 20 years
we're surprisingly ineffective at that
at closing the differences that we see
between low income and high income
children in some cases those gaps have
actually gotten worse in the us in the
last 25 years
so what else could help level the
playing field
professor catherine page harden is a
psychologist and geneticist who argues a
new approach is needed
she believes understanding children's
genetics could be key
from a genetic perspective we can see
that people who happen to inherit
certain genetic variants are more likely
to graduate from college
i think we're really used to thinking
about the role that a child's family
background plays in equality and
inequality over the course of their life
and what we're seeing with the research
now is that genetics plays just a bigger
role in shaping these types of
inequalities and life outcomes
professor hardin argues genetics could
be used to identify the children least
likely to do well at school and that
this offers the potential for better and
more effective interventions to help
them you can have children spit into a
tube and for less than 75 american
dollars you can get a readout of their
dna which can be used to see okay we
know for some reason these kids with
these genetic variants are less likely
in 30 years to have graduated from
college or gotten a phd
is this so exciting
she says that some existing
interventions which don't take account
of genetics could be improved
is that intervention working
disproportionately for people who are
most likely to succeed in school or
least likely or is it working about the
same for everyone so far those questions
are really unknown because
interventionists haven't really
incorporated genetic tools into their
research design
there's nothing that the state of north
carolina do
to justify what they did to me
the idea of using genetic information to
shape social policy provokes strong
reactions it has a very dark and
uncomfortable past
in the 20th century genetic traits were
used to promote the idea of racial
superiority
sometimes in disturbing propaganda i
think many people worry because they say
that's a way of dismissing a large chunk
of the population they talk about
genetic determinism being right wing
[Music]
but professor hardin believes it doesn't
have to be like this we see these real
fears that genetic information will be
used to naturalize hierarchy at the same
time we see
an increasing embrace of thinking about
our biology in relation to sexual
orientation in relation to weight how
does my genotype affect my difficulty of
keeping off weight so what i'd like to
see is for that trend to continue but
around things related to academic
achievement
achievement
or educational attainment
using genetic information like this is
still a long way off
its advocates will have to show that it
can be done in a safe and ethical way
and that it will improve social mobility
rather than increasing existing
inequalities
parents and children see that the dna
revolution is here they want to know how
it's affecting them i expect it to be
really scientifically interesting and
productive area of research moving
forward
[Music]
hi i'm adrian wooldridge political
editor here at the economist if you'd
like to read more about social mobility
then click on the link opposite
and if you'd like to watch more in our
now or next series click on the other
link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
you